♪
>> Will: THE U.S. INVOLVEMENT IN
AFGHANISTAN COMES TO AN END, WE
STILL HAVE SOME IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS AND IMPORTANT MISSION.
HERE IS ONE.
LEAVING WITH HONOR.
WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE THE U.S.
WAS NOT ALONE IN THE FIGHT
AGAINST TERROR.
AS THOUSANDS OF LOCAL AFGHAN
CITIZENS PUT THEIR LIVES ON THE
LINE TO HELP US.
WE PROMISED TO PROTECT THEM AND
THEY NEED OUR HELP NOW.
WE OWE IT TO THEM.
BUT, WE ALSO OWE IT TO
OURSELVES, TO ENSURE THAT THESE
REFUGEES ARE PROPERLY VETTED
BEFORE THEY COME TO THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA.
SO HOW DO WE DO THIS?
AND HOW DO WE HONOR NOT JUST
WHAT WAS SACRIFICED ON THE
BATTLEFIELD BUT ALSO THOSE WE
LOST IN SEPTEMBER OF 2001.
ARE WE PAYING RESPECT TO OUR
FALLEN LOVED ONE AND SOLDIERS OF
9/11.
AS WE RETREAT FROM AFGHANISTAN.
ALMOST 20 YEARS OF A GOING IN?
FRANK SILLER LOST HIS BROTHER
STEVE ON THE ATTACK TWIN TOWERS
AND KNOWS THE BURDENS THESE
CARRY.
AND SEAN PARNELL SERVED IN
AFGHANISTAN.
THEY JOIN ME NOW.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR BEING HERE.
SEAN, CAN WE STATE-OF-THE-ART
WITH THE REFUGEES FOR JUST ONE
MOMENT, THE TRANSLATORS THAT
HELPED US?
>> SURE.
>> Will: I KNOW MANY MEN WHO
FOUGHT OVER THERE KNOW HOW MUCH
THEY CONTRIBUTED TO THE EFFORT.
WHAT DO WE OWE THEM?
>> WELL, FIRST, I WILL JUST SAY
THE BEST WAY TO TAKE CARE OF
THOSE PEOPLE IS TO HAVE A
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF THAT WAS
FULLY ENGAGED ON A RESPONSIBLE
EXIT STRATEGY.
IT'S DIFFICULT TO -- IT'S
DIFFICULT TO DESCRIBE IN WORDS
THE DISASTER THAT'S UNFOLDING IN
AFGHANISTAN.
IT WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS WHOLLY
PREVENTABLE.
AND JOE BIDEN TOTALLY BOTCHED
IT.
AND I WOULD ALSO SAY, WILL, THAT
THIS ISN'T AS CLEAR CUT AS YOU
MIGHT THINK.
15 YEARS AGO TODAY, ACTUALLY, WE
HAD AN INTERPRETER THAT OPERATED
WITH US THAT FOUGHT WITH US,
THAT BLED WITH US, THAT CHARGED
INTO THE TEETH OF THE ENEMY WITH
US AND THEN TURNED ON US AND
KILLED ONE OF MY SOLDIERS TODAY.
15-YEAR ANNIVERSARY OF HIS DEATH
HIS NAME IS JEREMY KOHL.
WE'LL NEVER FORGET HIM.
WILL, 20 YEARS WE HAVE BEEN IN
AFGHANISTAN, RIGHT?
20 YEARS WE BLED, WE FOUGHT FOR
THE FREEDOM OF THE PEOPLE OF
AFGHANISTAN.
WE WENT INTO THAT COUNTRY AFTER
9/11, AFTER THOUSANDS WERE
KILLED.
WE GAVE THEM AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
FREEDOM.
WE LOST THOUSANDS OF OUR OWN
PEOPLE.
WOUNDED TENS OF THOUSANDS MORE.
IS IT NOT OKAY TO ASK THE
QUESTION HOW CAN OUR ALLIES,
PERHAPS, HONOR THAT GREAT
SACRIFICE AS WELL?
OF COURSE WE WANT TO TAKE CARE
OF OUR REFUGEES.
OF THE INTERPRETERS WHO FOUGHT
WITH US AS LONG AS THEY ARE
VETTED FIRST.
I THINK IT'S INCUMBENT UPON ALL
AMERICANS TO SHARE BURDEN AS
WELL.
>> Will: FRANK, I WANT TO GET TO
YOU IN A MOMENT AS WELL.
LET ME FOLLOW ONE SEAN, I'M NOT
SURPRISED WHAT YOU ARE SAYING.
GREEN ON BLUE KILLINGS, THE
KILLING OF AMERICAN SOLDIERS BY
OUR SUPPOSED AFGHAN ALLIES.
SO HOW DO WE BALANCE THAT REALLY
QUICKLY HERE, SEAN BECAUSE I
WANT TO GET FRANK, IN HOW DO WE
BALANCE THAT TO UPHOLD OUR HONOR
AND WHAT WE OWE THOSE WHO HELPED
US BUT ALSO PROTECT AMERICANS
BECAUSE WE CAN'T JUST FLOOD
AMERICA WITH REFUGEES THAT ARE
FULLY UNVETTED.
>> WELL, LOOK, I MEAN, I WOULD
JUST SAY THIS.
IS 20 YEARS OF BLOOD AND
TREASURE, SACRIFICE ON THE
GROUND OF AFGHANISTAN ENOUGH?
I HAVE LOST OVER 40 OF MY
FRIENDS, LIKE RISKED OF MY LIFE
FOR THAT COUNTRY, MY MEN RISKED
THEIR LIFE FOR THAT COUNTRY.
WE GAVE THEM A SHOT AT FREEDOM.
AT SOME POINT THEY HAVE TO STAND
UP AND FIGHT FOR THEIR OWN.
I'M NOT SAYING WE SHOULD ABANDON
THEM ON THE BATTLEFIELD.
WE SHOULD HAVE HAD AN
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE TO VET
THESE PEOPLE PRIOR TO OUR EXIT
STRATEGY EVEN BEGINNING.
>> Will: RIGHT.
>> SO, NOW, UNFORTUNATELY, IT'S
ALMOST TOO LATE.
WE CAN FIGURE -- WE CAN HAVE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW WE CAN
GO IN AFTER BUT THIS BOTCHED
EXIT STRATEGY MAKES IT FAR MORE
DIFFICULT, WILL.
>> Will: YEAH, WE SEE IMAGES AND
I'M SORRY TO RUSH YOU ALONG,
SEAN, YOU HAVE AN IMPORTANT
MESSAGE HERE.
WE SEE THE IMAGES OF C-17s
FULL OF REFUGEES.
WE HAVE BASES ALL OVER THE
WORLD.
ALLIES ALL OTHER THE WORLD.
THERE NEEDS TO BE A PROCESS PUT
IN PLACE NOW.
FRANK, I WANT TO TURN TO YOU.
YOU LOST YOUR BROTHER ON 9/11.
WE WENT TO AFGHANISTAN BECAUSE
OF 9/11.
CAN YOU HELP SHARE THE
PERSPECTIVE OF A FAMILY OF A
VICTIM OF SEPTEMBER 11TH?
HOW DO YOU FEEL TODAY AS YOU
WATCH AFGHANISTAN UNFOLD?
>> WELL, MY HEART BREAKS FOR ALL
9/11 FAMILIES, BUT EVEN MORE FOR
THOSE GOLD STAR FAMILIES WHO
LOST THEIR LOVED ONES, OUR MEN
AND WOMEN WHO GAVE THEIR LIVES
PROTECTING US HERE ON OUR
HOMELAND SO ANOTHER 9/11
WOULDN'T HAPPEN.
AND, LISTEN, OUR COUNTRY HAS TO
BE BETTER THAN THE SCENES THAT
YOU ARE SEEING OVER THERE NOW.
THERE IS A WAY TO DO IT AND DO
IT RIGHT.
AND TO PROTECT THE AFGHANYS THAT
THAT HELPED US FIGHT THE WAR ON
TERROR.
WE OWE IT TO THEM TO BRING THEM
HERE ON OUR SHORES AND PROTECT
THEM.
LOOK, I NEVER WANT TO FORGET
WHAT HAPPENED ON 9/11.
I'M MORE WALKING FROM THE
PENTAGON TO SHANKSVILLE TO
GROUNDS ZERO COMMEMORATING THE
20 YEARS WHERE I LOST MY BROTHER
WHILE HE RAN INTO A BUILDING
WITH HIS FIRE GEAR ON SAVING
PEOPLE'S LIVES.
AND THIS YEAR WE ARE READING
OVER 7,000 NAMES ON VETERANS DAY
THE ONES WHO GAVE THEIR LIFE ON
THE WAR ON TERROR.
I DON'T BELIEVE IT'S EVER BEEN
DONE.
WE ARE GOING TO READ IT AT THE
LINCOLN CENTER ON VETERANS DAY.
WE CAN'T FORGET WE HAVE LOST
OVER 7,000 MEN AND WOMEN.
>> Will: FRANK, YOU ARE ON THAT
500-MILE WALK.
IT'S AN AWESOME THING YOU ARE
DOING.
YOU HAVE BEEN DOING AWESOME
THINGS FOR THE LAST I DON'T KNOW
HOW MANY YEARS, FRANK, BUT YOU
ARE ON THIS 500-MILE WALK.
WE ARE APPROACHING THE 20TH
ANNIVERSARY OF 9/11.
WHAT DOES IT SAY TO YOU, WHAT
DOES IT MEAN TO YOU ON THIS 9/11
ANNIVERSARY AND I WILL PUT THIS
TO BOTH OF IF YOU CAN ANSWER
VERY QUICKLY THE TALIBAN WILL BE
REINSTITUTED AS THE LEADERS OF
AFGHANISTAN?
WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK WHERE WE
STARTED FROM, FRANK.
>> WELL, IT'S VERY UPSETTING FOR
SURE.
I THINK THAT WE HAVE MORE
INTELLIGENCE NOW THAN WE EVER
HAD.
AND I DON'T BELIEVE THAT OUR
COUNTRY WILL LET THAT HAPPEN
AGAIN.
AT LEAST I PRAY FOR THAT BECAUSE
I DON'T WANT OTHER FAMILIES TO
GO THROUGH WHAT 2977 FAMILIES
HAD TO GO THROUGH 20 YEARS AGO.
WE WILL NEVER FORGET THE TUNNEL
TO TOWERS FOUNDATION STANDS BY
THAT AND THAT IS OUR FIRST
MISSION.
OF EVERYTHING WE DO.
WE PAY OFF THE MORTGAGE AS YOU
KNOW FOR GOLD STAR FAMILIES.
WE BUILD ESPECIALLY ADAPTED
SMART HOMES FOR CATASTROPHICALLY
INJURED SERVICE MEMBERS BUT OUR
FIRST MISSION IS TO NEVER
FORGET.
>> Will: I HAVE GOT TO RUN,
SEAN.
LISTEN, I APPRECIATE BOTH OF
YOUR INPUT TODAY.
I APPRECIATE THE PERSPECTIVE OF
SOMEONE WHO FOUGHT THERE AND
SOMEONE WHO SUFFERED FROM
TERRORISM HER